oh but - but oh no he's gonna have sex
with the cow isn't he yeah
[Music]
so listen I brought you here today cuz
just to be clear these are set up by an
outside producer right so I brought you
here because we're doing a great cartoon
I've always wanted to show you called
Molly Moo Cow and Robinson Caruso yeah
waiting forever okay so yeah everybody's
already like caught up with Robinson
Crusoe they're like what a story of
people are eight story what if Molly moo
cow were to meet oh that's right
everyone loves Molly yeah get her on the
island but like anything at the time
this is really just there's no issues
with it it's really nice it's a sweet
story mm-hmm I don't know you'll see
it's hard - okay it's hard to know what
to prepare myself for would be fine when
you bring me over for these thanks for
coming to my house but not your house
you didn't this is not cribs Bert
Gillette now Bert EULA had made this
cartoon he was at what some people would
call it drunk sir before we got into the
race and here he he fired like 50
technicolor yep
obviously music by winston sharp or
classic charles molly moo-cow wow you
weren't lying okay this is real they
only fired fifty fifty cartoon this
while making this so this is just
classic cow stuff was this like a milo
notice story where they're like actually
50 cows and they were just like throwing
them in the river
that's I don't know why you bring that
up right now but so this is why cows
don't go in the water sure I you know
I've not seen a lot of swimming cows
well they don't usually go to the ocean
skinny skinny and what does he have on
boxing gloves um no this is just as fee
well first of all it's she right Molly
yeah yeah I really you don't know
anything words right or it's a dude on
Molly okay could be really in the
present mode wait he does have horns she
she has horns so cuz I'm like this for
an hour Oh God
yeah really needs not some fresh water I
wish that you could do that so far
well the way that it goes there it goes
into the tail sure so Molly was just out
sailing right right on her on her boat
loves bananas yeah classic cow stuff now
that's Robin that's Robinson Crusoe well
he's eating like a king out here yeah
his I think he'd be starving it looks
like he might be like I got a stuff I
gotta cut back no there's just so much
food on the side I mean I ate the whole
family I am stuffing he's got a giant
stomach he painted his belly button for
a gun he's also not good at standing all
by my so people never told us how small
his legs were got it something about how
happy he is all alone loves it
who could see this coming Co Oh God
well that guns really not good Wow all
right well how many does it hold it's a
buckshot
no wonder he's eating so well the guns
bad that's about the NRA dream all right
so there's a lot of rocks on the beach
see they can't find each other they're
scared of each other sure you get it I
do oh but - but hahaha
Oh oh no he's gonna have sex with the
cow isn't he yeah oh that's gross see
but no I like how affectionate castle
yeah a dozen want to be licked guy does
want to be licked
I said his his heart is blackened on the
island yeah get away from it
Wow deal that got weird why wouldn't you
shoot the cow no you're on an island you
don't go further than what the cartoon
does I shoot the cow oh I should come
right back wait I don't know oh yeah oh
this is getting this is yeah that's this
is sex
where is nipples and belly but that's
I'm worried about that if you lick it
lick from your feet to your head it's
sex
oh well now we're off now we're gonna go
somewhere new this is a real will they
won't thing you see these two are really
men freak weather whoa what that's gotta
hurt the old taint absolutely a taint
crusher
he built the fort sure while he wrote
his songs about how he wants to be alone
so this is more of a dog yeah as a cow
sure you could domesticate most animal
that gives more of a hobo than he was a
Robinson Crusoe
yeah well he's again I mean he's
obviously been drinking seawater Oh
now how'd you get howdy I'm the one who
gets to ask the questions how the hell
did Molly get in there that's not true
what if he just put it in his mouth he
wants the cow off the whole island he's
a real [ __ ] all right okay yeah it's
okay you're quite a cat I got off the
island all right stop stop go go go oh
now he's got a belly button okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah I'm happy again
hey Malone yeah but Molly yeah she's out
there Joe versus the volcano ik right oh
this is not good if I got a bad feeling
Oh have I got a bad feeling what when
the racism is about to happen
yep
[Music]
they have bones in their hair help is
kind of my sentiment Wow
I mean maybe they just didn't know how
to end it so they're like what about
racism it comes out of nowhere I'm going
to go back to the cow part Wow
just Jesus Christ go back don't go back
a turnaround making racist cartoons back
there Mali personal not out logs work
for sure how logs work not how cows work
no none of this is real no God please
tell me this is where she stabs the
animator I know how we end it yeah go in
there this is hilarious when you put
your ass on everyone's guns when they
lay up oh oh she's going to help
Robinson Caruso because obviously these
people are the enemy for sure right yeah
well they're right yeah oh yeah it's
right you can just throw the guns oh
yeah okay oh boy oh dear why did this
part happen who what the get out I'm
glad that cut at hand oh no no no no no
no no no what wide wide what dave is it
weird she's not a weirdo God why was
that weird at the end my god what just
happened and that is your end yeah
Oh God even the cows are racist I think
um I think we all learned an important
lesson there don't keep doing these the
guy who directed that web ended up in a
mental hospital because of stuff like
that oh I just wasn't well here Randy
went crazy from doing the cow blackface
yeah huh not that easy I guess I feel
good
you